awesome so thank you very much for
coming so in this talk I would like to
go deep into interesting question which
is what makes Python Python right so we
have two main parts that people
recognize usually as Python one is the
interpreter which is normally when you
type Python you'd probably see Python
the one will appears which is the
default implementation but the
interpreter can be done in many
languages as well
we have other implementations for
example in Java like JSON or item Python
so that part can actually so see Python
is not technically what would make
Python Python so there is another part
what people usually recognize as Python
which is the grammar right the kind of
problems you write and expression as you
do so in this particular talk we are
going to Center on all the world
surrounding that particular aspect of
the language and how tiny technical
details of how is made up will impact a
lot the code you write so I will start
with an interesting question so the
question is is this valid Python code
only like 10 seconds who thinks is
pollak Python code like razor ham who
thinks is invalid well this doesn't add
up right okay so actually it is valid
Python code and this is the ast of this
thing so you don't need to understand it
just that this means that Python is able
to parse this code so some some clever
stuff like this is actually like - some
bigger van and this is the Lipsey's
thing so but it resembles some something
horrible right and yeah that with this
what I want to say that the code that
people normally recognize as Python is
actually a tiny subset of what the
language actually allows and there is
some very twisted ways of writing valid
Python programs right and in this talk
we are going to try to understand how
these rules are actually layout and with
impact they have okay so so let's start
with some grammar basics right because
we are talking about the grammar so the
grammar is basically a document that
explains what is valid Python right so
let's start with how this document is
described so we are going to have rules
right and the rules are basically
described as
a name for the rule which is also a
production and then some description of
what the rule is so you have to put in
mind that with the grammar describes
exactly how to generate Python programs
so the parser actually what the is going
to do is that it's going to grab the
grammar and it's going to sort of
reverse-engineer so in the opposite
question which is given a particular
text is this a Python program that can
be generative total grammar but you have
to worry mind that the grammar is laid
out in a way it actually makes it very
easy to say okay give me a random Python
problem so in that way we will have
rules here and then rule descriptions on
the second side so we can have many
descriptions for the same rules so this
basically means that this rule can
actually produce these two things
instead usually instead of doing in this
way we use the or operator so this means
that this rule can be this chunk or this
other chunk we will also have the plus
sign so the plac sign means one or more
this means that this rule is one letter
a or more than one it's very similar to
regular expressions but it's actually
much more powerful than them but you can
familiarize more or less how to describe
this thing if you have in mind regular
expressions so in the same way we have
the asterisk which means zero or more
then we will have these square brackets
which means this is optional so we will
have something like this rule means that
you can have an a or this particular
other rule and this particular other
rule can be optional in that particular
example and then so this is the actual
so now that we have more or less but in
mind this is the act or Graham a chunk
of the actor grammar of Python right so
let's see how we interpret this thing so
we're starting the first rule which is
file input and then we say that
basically a file what you can write in a
file is start with a new line and then
like zero or more statements and then
the end of the file so you say okay what
is a statement so then you go here and
you say okay I statement is a simple
statement or a compound statement and
then you say okay what is a simple
statement I said okay it's a small
statement or a cetera cetera right and
then in the component streaming we see
things that we more or less recognize
already right like if statement while
statement so all of these are things
that are possible and it is that the
whole document with this espana subset
will basically describe what is possible
in their armor and then we have to
distinguish two possible inputs here so
one is let's go here yeah so one of
these is what we call a terminal so a
terminal here is a word which is
surrounded by quotes this mean like
literally this worse so for example for
the wireless statement we expect the
world while and then we have this non
terminal so if you mind this grammar as
a tree the terminals are the leaves and
a non terminal any intermediate node
right so a non terminal basically
something that you need to expand it
basically refers to another rule so one
thing which is not super important here
but one thing is that if if the
basically the grammar is written away
that is sort of substitution so
basically you have here a rule and then
you have always the description of the
rule at the end it's called a
context-free grammar this other
definition for a but the idea that that
simplifies a lot of things and maybe is
that we have to be we'll see later how
this thing play but it's very important
to this thing with these two terms
because the words that you can write at
the beginning of the rule or the words
that can start the rule will impact a
lot how how certain structures are
allowed in cpython so I skip this this
slide so this is another part of the
grammar so we will see the statements
that we mentioned before right so we saw
that component statement can be any of
these and then we start seeing so for
example an if statement is the word if
followed by something that evaluates to
a condition or an object you may that
can be true or false then the column and
then this suite is basically a block
what people recognize usually as a block
is coffee and a gram of it and then you
have the leaf and all the stuff so it is
that we have this document right with
this kind of rules which basically
describe what is what is possible to
write and what is not so let's analyze
the impact that it has or the particular
things that cpython imposes over this so
particularly the C Python grammar is
another one grammar so let's see what is
this so another one grammar is a grammar
that is parts left to right do the
leftmost derivation which means that you
analyze first the talking which is on
the on the left and the you star
spanning from that and this is the most
important rule which is that when you
are parsing like the parser when it's
analyzing up
the girl program is comparing it with
the rammer can only look one token on
the on the like one tock is not a hat
which means that if I need to
distinguish a rule like mind you have a
particular rule which has two
possibilities slide two productions and
then I need to distinguish which one of
the two is the correct one so for doing
that I can only look the next token in
the input right so for example if you
are doing something like for X in range
something and I find the word for if I
need to distinguish two different
productions I can only look one token
ahead with will be these X in example I
put so it turns out that this is a very
well-known problem how to solve like
this actually leads to very simple
parsers but the Python grammar has two
more particularities that may the parts
are even simpler for the ones that know
more a bit of grammar theory basically
this is a partially generated with a
partial table with what is known as the
first cells and the photo shows more on
this later but particularly we have two
more things here one is that the Python
grammar doesn't allow empty productions
this means that every rule has to be
something that doesn't end in the empty
string so an empty production is
basically a rule that can be empty and
this makes the parts are more difficult
because if you have rules that can be
empty and you can only look one token
ahead then if the rule is empty you need
to actually look to so that's what leads
to what is called the follow sets so we
because we don't need them I know in
displaying this tone and then we have
another kind of rule which is a bit more
lucy and this is not actually enforced
but is basically the grammar is laid out
in a way which means that in some levels
only the last alternative are route and
how a non-terminal so for example we can
she oops okay so for example let's see
this one so if you see this so the
flower stamen so we have break continued
return price and deal so you check all
of them except Jill they start with a
non-terminal right so for example breaks
terminus start with break continues ten
minutes that we continue etcetera a
dhaba the only one who actually start
with a non-terminal is deal statement
which is here a non-terminal called deal
expression so this is more or less
layout and this simplifies a bit more
how the first sets are layout on and it
makes easier to produce the parsing so
okay so this is more or less the grammar
so let's let's
describe what is this first sense so the
first search for a rule for example a
simple statement are all the
non-terminals the rule can start with
and this is very important because as we
saw before if we are only allowed to
look at the next token and we we need to
see if a particular rule is valid it
will be very interesting to know all the
possible tokens that rule kind of start
with right because if we have that token
and the token is in one of these
particular non terminals that are
allowed then we know that we are good
because it's possible that that rule has
that start with that token but if we
have a particular token and then we are
trying to pass a rule and that rule does
not start with that token we know that
is invalid so we can say that is a
syntax error right so this is what is
called the first set and it's going to
be very important later so this is the
first set of sound of the expression so
for example playing can only start with
Priene brace can only start with raise
but simple statement can start with all
of these things okay so let's see how
the parser works so see Python actually
doesn't have a hand written parser it
has a parser generator so it's a tool
that generates the parser for us from
the grammar file which makes it much
much more less error-prone because you
don't need to manually modify the parser
every time you generate more grammar
rules so let's see how it works so it's
actually a very simple thing so we start
with the grammar in extended back use
not form which is the document now we
saw before and this will product this
will produce non-deterministic finite
automata so we will see what it is
basically these things are just control
graph flow so you like this kind of
drawing when you have nodes and arrows
telling you which option you have we'll
see some examples and the things that
this these initial things are very
simple to produce but they are very
complicated is full of errors and
complexity so the the step that grabs
one of these and convert them in with
this correlator manectric funny automata
is basically simplifying it and making
it more more easy to to follow so let's
see one example so let's say we start
with this rule which is the rule for
factors right like a plus B a minus B
not something right so this is this is
the rule so then the first thing that
the part the parser generator produces
the non-deterministic finite automata
which is this control graph right so we
will study in this state and then we
will go down until we start seeing this
this
so that is that do you start here and
then you read some particular program
that is trying to follow that rule and
if you are able to go from the state to
the end then the rule is correct if you
are not able to go to from the start to
the end then the rule is invalid so you
mind that instead of plus minus and till
L you have asterisk right which is no
part of this rule in particular so this
didn't you kind of follow here because
there is no step that has the SD it's
actually hidden in power so it's a valid
Python program but if you don't look at
power for now you can imagine how you
cannot follow this in now so this is
very complicated because in 30 you can
only follow the arrows if one of the
tokens is allowed so it for example for
this day for two state eight is very
easy to know if you can follow because
if you find the minus sign then you can
go ahead but if you don't find the minus
sign that you cannot follow it and the
problem is that we have here in the
non-deterministic automata we have some
stages which we don't know if we can
like follow them or not for example for
going for in a state zero two state one
or two we don't have any particular sign
to follow so that is a problem because
we don't know if we can where the rule
to transition to the other states or not
that's the complicated part of the
non-deterministic finite automata so the
next step is to produce a deterministic
one which is that one so in this case as
you can see all the states the only
transition between a state and something
is followed by a particular token so for
example if one in a state 0 we just need
to look on the next light token in the
input either plus minus or till and if
it's not any of these we say that the
rule is invalid if it's one of these
then we follow it and we Furr go to
state one and state one goes to another
rule call factor but as you can see in
this particular true a DFA sorry yeah
DFA there is not transition between
state and states with our unknown
transition but you can see something
which is still bad which is for example
this node which is here isolated this
dog is rubbish it doesn't mean anything
it just means that when we transform
this thing into this thing we produce
some things which are either tremely
complicated or they can't they're
basically Travis which has no states so
the next step is simplifying the thing
into what is called the final DFA so
basically is removing complexity and
removing this this particular node so
this is basically what it is is
producing this kind of control flow
diagrams which are still very
complicated with some particular
algorithm
you transform this to this which is very
known on old and from these dude runs
some simplification which is called
minimization algorithm and then you
produce those here and this this
particular diagram is what the parser
follows if you think about this is more
or less like hash table or a dictionary
so basically you are in a particular
state and then you look at the possible
keys here are plus minus or tilde and if
you have them in the dictionary or the
hash table then you transition to
whatever value you have and if you don't
just say that the British involved so
that makes actually the parsers so much
so fast because it's basically some sort
of hash table lookup again and again and
again nest and these these rules here so
for example when you Oh to power like
the square box in power you have another
of these basically describing with a
particular sub rule is so it's basically
nested dioramas instead of nested
diagrams so let's take some examples
here so for example we can see the roof
or composition so in this example you
always will have the the complicated one
right a non DFA on the left then the DFA
here and the simplified one here so you
more or less can can see what kind even
if you know exactly the algorithm which
is not super complicated but it will
take a lot of time to explain you can
see more or less or you can feel the
kind of simplification that the parser
start doing so this is for example for
comparing things between them this is
the rule for like the comparison but
with the actual tokens so you will see
things that you recognize as comparison
operator like note equals less than
bigger than so you can see actually how
when the rule is actually a bit more
complicated the non DFA is actually a
monster and this non DFA is actually
very well simplify I didn't put the one
in the middle because it's still it
doesn't fit in in the particular screen
so we can see more so for example this
is the decorator and this is a very
interesting example because you can see
actually from a very high point of view
what you can decorate so for example in
the room for decorative things you can
see that you can decorate a sinc
functions class the finishes and
functions and you can articulate
anything more because the rule doesn't
allow that at the end we will see a way
of having things to this so you can play
a bit later but you can see how these
things are actually even if you don't
see the rules and only you see this kind
of automate as we found something lower
you can still recognize more or less
what is valid or what is describing more
of these you have the factor internal we
saw before so you can see how here in
the non DFA we have still this
transition between states and in the
like and one we have only transition
between the two become numbers and you
can see how they they actually much more
simplify so I want to show you my
favorite one which is this one so this
one is the the diagram that parses
function definitions which is this
monster but don't worry because this is
the non DFA right so let's see the
simplified version which is much clearer
to read this not so this is the most
complicated rule but this duration is so
complicated and this is one of the
things we are going to see at the end so
the reason it's so complicated is
because the way we need to describe this
rule is actually fighting the ll 1
limitation so the little one a lot of
people see it as a blessed because they
say ok because it's a so simple grammar
that has this very strong conditions
that make them black very strict then
it's very difficult to have like very
complicated rules which is good because
at the end you want Python to be simple
and readable and like not like other
languages C++ so but there is a problem
which is that sometimes what the user
perceives has a very simple rule is
actually not that simple or at least you
cannot describe it there's another one
rule in that particular case you need to
do a hack and you will see many hacks in
the grammar which is called full life
expansion which is literally grabbing
all the three and expand it at the end
because you cannot have like these
limitations will are rising away but
there is there is a way of solving this
limitation which is having a rule full
of non terminals and in that way you
don't have this problem because you
don't need to deal with first set
because it's all non terminals and the
reason this particular rule is so
complicated is because this is one of
them this is the most complex example of
the most beast example okay so let's
continue so let's see what limitations
on the other one grammar are so one
particular example for example they see
let's see these rules so this rule we
have is whatever rule and it will start
with the
were due then some particular sepulchral
a thing while an expression and then we
have another possibility for the rule
which is the same style except that it
has another brutal Kolbe and then we go
to the first set we remember our the
non-terminals a root canister with and
we see that a canister with the letter A
or the letter B and we can start with a
little a or the letter C right then
let's say we are trying to parse this
input right there you should write that
and we want to see if is a correct
program in this case we know that is the
first choice like the first rule because
if we go to the first set this B can
only be on the first set of capital A so
we know is this particular here right
because this a can only start with a
I'll Kotori with D and we have B so the
option bay doesn't have been inside so
we know it's not be but let's say the
user writes that code so now we have a
problem because this particular
lowercase a appears in both so is this
one or is this one so we don't know and
this makes the rule ambiguous because
you don't know which one of the two
right because if you go with all the
tokens that the root can start they
share one of these non terminals so when
you find this a you don't know which
route to choice and this is a problem
because this route is embodied in
another one and this is the limitation
right this is what makes ambiguous do
you cool if you have a more powerful
parser and then you say okay but in mine
that I'm able to like follow and read
more tokens from do backtracking then
you can distinguish this one or this one
but because we are only allowed to look
at the next token we we kind of right so
we we're passing do and then we look at
the next token we find a and then we
know we don't know what to fall and
that's the problem so this happens in C
Python so actually it happens a lot so
for example this is the rule that
describes how to pass arguments how to
code functions and particularly I want
you to look at this argument rule so
let's let's see what the argument is
okay so we have test is basically an
object so 3 4 X whatever then we have
the keyword argument so a particular
name equal and an object and then we
have a star star like dictionary
unpacking and listen packet right so
this rule is actually not nobody because
if we look at the first sets of tests so
this one it actually contains name
so these two are ambiguous because if
you are here and you say okay I will I
want to choose this one or this one and
then you find name you don't know it to
choose this one because tests also start
with name so you don't know which one to
follow so this makes these rules not
possible but you can still call
functions in Python right so how is made
so this is one of the first hack we have
which is the actual rule is test equal
test and this rule allows to through
things like list comprehension equal to
this comprehension or dictionary
comprehension equal to the canary
comprehension and then you say wait wait
but I cannot write a same Python right
so the reason is that we allow the thing
on the parcel of the parser is pretty
happy with that but when it comes to the
ast which is much later in the in the
compiled pipeline we say by a way this
test actually anything other than just a
name like keyword if it's not then say
syntax error it just doesn't occur or
doesn't happen on the parcel but you
don't know so little lies that we have
another interesting one is the you know
the water separator so the water
separator also suffer this so this is
the rule for the water separator which
is like a particular name The Walrus
operator and an object and this has the
same problem right because the first set
of tests also include name and you say
hey but I don't see the pipe right so
it's not this or or this thing why do
you think about is the same case because
because this is optional right so if you
are saying okay I need to pass the scene
over I actually have this optional path
so because you can only look one token
and both can start with the word name
like a non-terminal name which is any
Python module then you know what to
choose so again you have the same
problem and the actual rule again is
this horrible thing and then we force it
much later as you can imagine this is
not very like
maintainable and then we have one that
Lukas here knows very well so this is
with the statements right and this is
valid Python 3 so in Python 3 you can
have multiple context managers in the
same with expression so you for handle
you can say with a sx b sy and then if
you have a lot of these then you say
well i don't want to put all of them in
the same line so if you want to continue
you use you need to use this line break
character right which is sort of okay
except that
this thing really mess with indentation
and out of her mother tools like black
cannot really format this thing but what
so you could do this thing if you allow
this thing which is put parentheses
around right so you see something like
okay so with open parentheses and then
you put all your context managers and
then you close parentheses this this
particular constructed very easy for out
though for matters because they know
what is the limited here right except
that this is invalid and you say why it
sounds like I mean I have seen this
thing before right I seen the scene in
the strings I say this thing imports
right you can say import and in open
parentheses and I want to thinks well it
turns out that if you analyze the rule
which is this one and then you want to
allow the parentheses then you say okay
so I'm going to write the same rule so
with and then I'm going to put two
possibilities right they all rule and
then I'm going to say open parenthesis
they all rule and close parentheses
right so it's either the rule or the
ruling between parentheses so again the
point of this is that this is ambiguous
because this guy which is the item also
kind of start with the open parenthesis
so you say with open parenthesis now you
don't know if the parent is belongs to
because you why three between
parentheses or because you are riprap
grouping with parentheses the whole rule
right and this is sad so we cannot
improve in that I'd really try okay so
you will see right so we have this dual
thing in how we square the grammar we
have a very powerful and simple way to
describe because we have another one
restriction and this makes not only the
parts are very fast but also very simple
to describe but then we have all these
weird things because we we want to put
some rules that we know they are simple
enough for users to use but all these
technical restrictions restive what you
can do and I want you to post here and
make you think about this because the
fact that they wrote the grammar is
little one and all these things is
they're actually very technical
implementation details right like this
is something of the user doesn't need to
know but this thing which is up the core
like really really deep down this thing
right now is percolating outside right
like even if you are not like writing C
Python and you're writing your own
interpreter and you want to fulfill
Python grammar even if you have the most
powerful parser right now you want to
run Bali Python you cannot write this
which is weird right is like the
implementation detail our portion in
something as important as the grammar
and and this is like sort of dangerous
and like worrying and beautiful at the
same time how this tiny technical
decisions can can affect so much like
what is a white Impala Python program so
at the end just to conclude this
particular step so with the person
produces what is call a parse tree so if
you write x plus y following all these
DFS and basically the arguing that we
saw it produces this particular
structure and if you substitute those
numbers to the actual rules you will
have this right so that 3 plus 4 or 1
plus 14 or something is this particular
work which is basically a flattened out
version of the diagram that we saw
before so this is what is fed to ast and
we are going to stop here because we are
going to talk about is this so this is
when the parser ends so what I'm going
to show you right now as a application
is how imagine that you want to create a
new grammar rule in C Python or in
Python right like I won't extend Python
for planar it so or or how we go
developers actually write new Rama rules
so they say you want to write this rule
right
so you have two objects and then you
want to implement the arrow operator
which is something that the user can
implement right so the user in my in
that the user has a class and the class
implements underscore underscore arrow
on the score underscore and you and
that's about something right and you
want to allowed to write a Aerobie and
it calls this particular function right
in the same way when you write a plus B
it goes down there ad so first you need
to do is up this token to the tokenizer
so sorry to the grammar so you go to the
grammar then you find the rule
describing multiplication division and
all the stuff and then you add the arrow
here right so we have the star the slash
all the things that are allowed and then
we say also the arrow so when you add
this thing and then you write the parser
generator you need to include the token
as a valid token right so in you go to
this particular file which is in C so we
are going to see a lot of C code and
then you say ok there is a new token
which is going to be called arrow and we
are not explained with token is at this
point so we just defining the existence
of the token so the idea is if you are
ok Shangri two of us now already very
fast
okay so then you go to the tokenizer and
describe how to parse the scene so you
find like a minus sign and then follow
like the bigger sign and you say okay
that's the arrow and you say return the
arrow then if you run the token I said
you will see that the tokenizer already
is able to parse the arrow so it's
actually very simple to do even if you
don't understand how I'm doing these
things so these three lines here is the
only thing you need to do for the ast
two parts so you don't need to
understand it you just need to say that
if you know what you're doing it's
actually very simple and then finally do
the only thing you need to do is
implement the actual operator so in this
case this is the bicycle for that which
means like you find a arrow B then pop a
poor beat call the function we described
in the arrow and then continue with
interpreter which is again very simple
you know what you're doing and finally
you just need to describe that there is
something called arrow and right arrow
which can be describing the objects
which is again these three lines plus
the header file and with that you can
write this code so you can create a
class that implements under Spanish Cora
arrow and in this case I'm going to map
the operator to the other and then you
can write this called F like arrow B and
it basically maps the function over the
list so as you see all these particular
men Dean Treanor so if you see all of
these particular like things make
implementing new rules as the one that
we show right now extremely simple but
they carry out all this danger and all
these impacts on on the language that
you see and appreciate so thank you very
much I'm sorry for some possible
you
you